that's the big issue everybody at this
point is either a DJ or an influencer
yeah it's it's some there's like six
degrees of separation you even know a DJ
yes or an influencer or you are one your
life you've seen everything change so
much from when you started you're a
podcaster yeah or a podcaster you've
seen it change so much is it better now
like just life in general is life in
general better now than it was when you
were growing up or do you feel like
it was it had was better than overall
it no it it's a that's a sliding scale
it's all like aspects of it right we're
better I think it was better that you
weren't staring at screens all the time
I think it's a better time now for
artists I think it's a better time now
for uh people who aren't white to be
able to express what's really happening
to them right uh uh I probably a worst
time now for people in hate groups where
they can kind of be like hey man I
didn't know you hated the same [ __ ] I
did you're up in Seattle right Sleepless
in Seattle that's the clan like you kind
of get that [ __ ] going on uh it's I
think it's just like but you know
obviously the environment we've kind of
pushed it to the Limit here it feels
like it's at the breaking point yeah I
feel bad for young people now that
they're kind of down to two seasons it's
either summer or winter it kind of seems
in a lot of places so and I think people
are ignorant too where they're looking
out at La and out here being like yeah
good luck like dude like that's not
gonna slowly come your yeah it's coming
it's coming yeah and when yeah if we
keep going this route because like I I
was looking back he saw you look at the
trees I got the Lush land and the lakes
and stuff and it's just like if it keeps
getting hotter all of those trees are
gonna dry out and then you might you
just sit around like a bunch of old
newspapers so yeah I think the new thing
is going to be uh it's not going to be
to solve it it's going to be the
fireproof house
where you can fire proof house with the
infinity pool inside I like that so as
you sit there and you watch people with
less money than you burning to death
right as you're tweeting my heart breaks
for people with less money than me you
stay in there yeah and once they're all
gone then you just sort of absorb yeah
and I think we're going to go back to
those massive ranches that guy like you
know like how that that one guy owned
Griffith Park like he gave that to La
like one guy had all of that I think
we're gonna go back to that once people
just sort of get you know burned out or
washed away by the Sea it's very
possible what's weird about La is we do
have a lot of homelessness but all of
our hit shows are about real estate like
every show on Netflix like selling
Sunset and you know buying things they
just start dressing like absolute
[ __ ] [ __ ] they're hookers hookers
yeah no no but I watched one of that
Orange County one this woman was selling
a house she's got these beautiful tits
probably not real right dude everything
but our areola yeah her tits were out
and then it plunged all the way down
here and I'm just thinking like if a guy
shows up with his wife right
like that's a really weird
thing where it says hey what'd you think
of that how it looked great
tell me two details of that house right
and none of them know like none of these
if you ask them what the taxes on the
house are they have no idea like they
don't know any real estate questions
they're just hot and I'm sure they know
but what I'm saying is they don't seem
to know that much
I would those are the kinds of women you
want to [ __ ] it as a guy if you're
successful yeah you want to stay away
from yeah because they will they will
they will take your life they'll eat you
yes yeah they'll eat you and then play
the victim and can't and cancel you
yeah well I mean they're they're well
yeah like look at like when I was a kid
that right there that was a movie star
right she was a movie star now she sells
houses she's selling a [ __ ] one level
ranch with an open floor plan yeah
how do you how do you not buy the house
the second you walk in there well and I
think a lot of them are are trading on
the fact that they'll meet Rich guys and
then perhaps you know they might marry
those guys
no you know what I think it is I think
it is that you never used to sell houses
on TV right and then what happened was
probably all the ugly people got shamed
out of that business right and then all
of a sudden they would just because back
in the day stewardesses were hot right I
think all the hot stewardesses are now
selling yeah because houses they are not
hot anymore they're not they look like
me no flight attendants look like
they're that's not true I've seen some
some of them are pretty but some of them
are weather no if you get on if you're
if you're on a uh uh a a mainstream
Airline flying across the country that's
seniority so there's going to be some
miles on that one right yeah if you take
a puddle jumper yes instead of playing
Denver you're doing Colorado Springs
right maybe Grand Junction right
that's where you get somebody who's is
cute yeah yeah yeah but at that point
but at that point I'm 54 so I can't look
at her anyways or else I'm a creep New
York to LA or LA to New York which is
what I do a lot is a lot of it's a lot
of older women yeah who have had it
they've had it they've had it I've had
it yeah they've had it yeah they're like
put the strap and they go the seat belt
they go and the shoulder strap like as
soon as I wear over they're like that
comic that stop writing jokes and he
hates his act right they just kind of
keep doing it keep rolling through but
what's interesting about uh what you
said about the fireproof houses that is
probably going to be kind of a reality
as stuff gets worse nobody's gonna the
sad thing is none of the politicians are
in a position to turn on corporations
right because they're they're all
grossly underpaid politicians and they
do it because they're supposed to be
public service but what you're really
doing is it's so the rich people can
have them in their pockets they they
need them that's why
um
you know the stuff that like those
24-hour news networks go after it's
never you know they're not going to go
after like the big guys that feed them
they go after you know stand-up
comedians telling jokes and uh you know
so yeah yeah some guy slap somebody at a
mall what is this what is happening to
the fabric of America and they just kind
of uh
they don't go after like Blackstone that
buys all these houses now and pushes the
values of them up and they've locked
people out of renting like they don't go
after companies like that like over the
pharmaceutical companies yeah they're
just selling liquor you know yeah
synthetic heroin that's right yeah
hundreds of thousands of people
devastating families there's one that's
not a big deal but did you see what Tim
Dillon said right right San Jose and
that's like uh
what do they call that when you're
you're like that joke I did uh at Red
Rocks when I saw a bunch of [ __ ]
liberal idiots out here going after dead
John Wayne right I'm speaking to dead
power like they were doing their thing
as a white person that day it was just
so [ __ ] stupid right settling scores
with dead people yeah putting them
historically introspective the a live
white guy that still has power that I
need to get my movie made I won't speak
to him right right but I'll try to
change the name of an airport yeah
you're welcome black people does that
ever do you think what changes that
where corporations run everything they
just seem to run everything and they
will forever
uh yeah yeah I think the the only game
to play now is yourself as far as just
try to be a nice person right an
individual I know I was talking to you
earlier I said hey I ran into this
squirrely little guy uh I mean watch
yourself if you're around you know just
[ __ ] like that yeah that's that's kind
of like um
you know I've been doing this bit in my
ACT about talking about what your job as
an older person is to help out younger
people right and whatever mistakes you
made you know you're selling this is
what I did this didn't work and this is
what worked and that's what you're
supposed to be doing and
um I I think that
you know if you're a comic that's doing
well you part of that of doing well is
helping out comics
that are are struggling
it just is and I think
you know if you're a white person you
should shut up and listen to people of
other races saying what their
experiences right rather than trying to
be like you know well actually you know
Africans actually sold black people into
slavery so uh slavery was like just
doing that that [ __ ] yeah that's not
helpful